Je vais un peu vous parler
de ma conférence à TEDxHouston.
Je me suis levée le matin suivant la conférence
avec la pire crise de vulnérabilité
de ma vie.
En fait je suis restée chez moi
pendant trois jours.
La première fois que je suis sortie c’était pour rencontrer une amie pour déjeuner.
Et en entrant, elle était déjà à table.
Je me suis assise et elle a dit,
« Mon Dieu, quelle tête tu as. »
J'ai dit, « Merci, Je me sens vraiment --
Comme si je ne marchais pas. »
Et elle m'a dit, « Qu'est ce qui se passe ? »
Et j'ai dit, « Je viens de dire
à 500 personnes
que je suis devenu chercheuse
pour éviter la vulnérabilité.
Et que quand la vulnérabilité
ressortait de mes données,
comme étant absolument essentielle
pour une vie bien vécue,
j'ai dit à ces 500 personnes
que j’ai fait une dépression.
J'avais une diapo qui mentionnait « dépression ».
A quel moment ai-je pensé que c'était une bonne idée? »
(Rires)
Et elle m'a dit : « J'ai vu ta conférence en live sur internet.
Ce n'était pas vraiment toi.
C'était un peu diffèrent de ce que tu fais normalement.
Mais c'était génial. »
Et j'ai dit,
« ça ne peut pas arriver.
YouTube, ils vont mettre tout ça sur YouTube.
Et je parlerai à 600, 700 personnes. »
(Rires)
Et elle m'a dit, « Je crois que c'est trop tard. »
Et j'ai dit, « Je vais te poser une question. »
Et elle m'a dit, « Oui. »
Et j'ai dit, « Tu te souviens quand nous étions à la fac
et nous étions libres et bêtes ? »
Et elle me dit, « Oui. »
Et j'ai dit, « Tu te rappelles avoir laissé des messages idiots
sur le répondeur de nos petits amis ?
Et ensuite nous devions nous introduire dans leur foyer
pour effacer l'enregistrement ? »
(Rires)
Et elle : « Euh… non. »
Donc bien sûr, la seule chose que je pouvais dire à ce point-là,
« Oui, moi non plus.
Que … moi non plus. »
Et je me dis,
« Brené, que fais-tu ? Qu'est que tu fais ?
Pourquoi tu ressors ça ? Tu as perdu la raison ?
Tes sœurs seraient parfaites pour ça."
Donc je relève la tête et elle dit,
« Tu veux vraiment t’introduire
et voler la vidéo
avant qu'ils ne la mettent sur YouTube ? »
Et j'ai dit, « Je suis juste en train d'y reflechir. »
(Rires)
Elle dit, « Tu es le pire exemple de vulnérabilité qu'il existe. »
Je l'ai donc regardé et j'ai dit une chose
qui à l'époque paraissait un peu dramatique,
mais qui a fini par être plus prophétique que dramatique.
J'ai dit,
« Si 500 se transforment en 1000
ou 2000,
ma vie est terminée. »
(Rires)
Je n'avais pas de plan de réserve pour 4 millions.
Et ma vie s’est terminée quand c’est arrivé.
Et le plus dur de la fin de ma vie est probablement
que j'ai appris une chose pénible sur moi-même,
qui est que,
même si j'étais frustrée
de ne pas pouvoir présenter mon travail au monde
Une partie de moi-même travaillait très dur
pour essayer de rester petite,
de rester en dessous des radars.
Mais je voulais parler de ce que j'avais appris.
J'ai appris deux choses l'année dernière.
La première est que
la vulnérabilité n'est pas faiblesse.
Et ce mythe
est terriblement dangereux.
Laissez-moi vous demander honnêtement
-- et je vous préviens,
je suis un psy,
je sais comment vous gêner --
si vous pouviez donc lever la main
combien d'entre vous, honnêtement,
en pensant à une action qui vous rendrait vulnérable
ou à dire quelque chose qui vous rendrait vulnérable,
se disent, « Mon Dieu, la vulnérabilité est une faiblesse. Ceci est une faiblesse »
Combien d'entre vous pensent que la vulnérabilité est un synonyme de faiblesse ?
La grande majorité.
Je vais vous poser une question:
Cette semaine à TED,
combien d’entre vous, en voyant la vulnérabilité ici sur scène,
ont pensé que c'était du pur courage ?
La vulnérabilité n'est pas une faiblesse.
Je défini la vulnérabilité
comme un risque émotionnel
une mise à nu, une incertitude.
Elle alimente nos vies quotidiennes.
Et j'en suis arrivée à la conviction --
c'est ma 12ème année de recherche --
que la vulnérabilité
est la mesure la plus précise que nous ayons
du courage --
être vulnérable, se mettre à nu,
être honnête.
Une des choses le plus bizarres qui soit arrivée.
est que, après l'explosion que fut ce TEDTalk,
j'ai reçu plein d'offres pour parler dans tout le pays --
des écoles aux réunions de parents
jusqu'aux entreprises de Fortune 500.
Et beaucoup des appels que j'ai reçu étaient du genre,
« Dr. Brown. Nous avons adoré votre TEDTalk.
On aimerait que vous veniez parler.
Nous vous serions reconnaissants
si vous n'évoquiez pas la vulnérabilité ou la honte. »
(Rires)
De quoi voulez-vous que je parle ?
Il y a trois grandes réponses.
Pour être honnête, ça vient surtout des secteurs:
innovation, créativité
et changement.
Alors laissez-moi vous dire
officiellement,
que la vulnérabilité est le berceau
de l'innovation, de la créativité et du changement.
(Applaudissements)
Créer signifie faire quelque chose
qui n'existait pas auparavant.
Il n'y a rien de plus vulnérable que ça.
L'adaptabilité au changement
est uniquement une question de vulnérabilité.
La deuxième chose,
que j'ajoute pour comprendre vraiment
la relation entre la vulnérabilité et le courage,
la deuxième chose que j'ai apprise est:
Nous devons parler de la honte.
Et je veux être vraiment honnête avec vous.
Quand je suis devenue « Chercheuse en vulnérabilité »
et que c'est devenu central à cause du TEDTalk --
et je ne plaisante pas.
Je vais vous donner un exemple.
Il y a à peu près trois mois, j'étais dans un magasin de sport
pour acheter des lunettes et des protège-tibias
et toutes sortes de choses que les parents achètent dans les magasins de sport.
A une trentaine de mètres, voilà ce que j'entends:
« TED Vulnérabilité ! TED Vulnérabilité ! »
(Rires)
Je suis une Texane de cinquième génération.
Notre devise de famille est « Prêts à l'attaque ! »
Je ne suis pas née chercheuse en vulnérabilité.
Donc ce que je fais,
c'est continuer à marcher, elle est derrière mon dos.
(Rires)
Ensuite j'entends, « TED Vulnérabilité ! »
Je me tourne, et je dis, « Salut »
Et elle est là et elle me dit,
« Vous êtes la chercheuse sur la honte qui a eu une dépression. »
(Rires)
A ce moment-là
les parents font mine d’écarter leurs enfants.
« Regarde ailleurs. »
Et je suis tellement usée à ce moment de ma vie,
que je la regarde et je dis,
« C'était un maudit éveil spirituel. »
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Et elle me regarde elle et dit,
« Je sais. »
Et elle dit,
« Nous avons regardé votre TEDTalk avec notre club de lecture.
Ensuite nous avons lu votre livre
et nous nous sommes rebaptisées
« Les nanas déprimées »
Et elle me dit, « Notre slogan est :
« On s'effondre, mais c'est une sensation fantastique. »
(Rires)
Vous pouvez imaginer
ce que ça veut dire pour moi en réunion de faculté.
Quand je suis devenue la « TED Vulnérabilité »,
comme une de ces figurine --
comme la « Barbie Ninja », mais je suis la « TED Vulnérabilité » --
j'ai pensé, je vais laisser toutes ces trucs de honte derrière moi,
parce que j'ai passé les six dernières années à étudier la honte
avant de vraiment commencer à écrire et parler de vulnérabilité.
Et j'ai pensé. Dieu merci, parce que la honte est un sujet horrible,
dont personne ne veut parler.
C'est le meilleur moyen de faire taire les gens dans un avion.
« Qu'est-ce que vous faites ? » « J'étudie la honte. » « Oh. »
(Rires)
Et droit dans les yeux…
Mais en ayant survécu cette année,
je me suis souvenue d'une règle très importante --
non pas une règle de la recherche,
mais un impératif moral
qui remonte à mon enfance --
mets-toi du côté de ceux qui te soutiennent.
Je n'ai rien appris sur la vulnérabilité
sur le courage et sur la créativité et l'innovation
en étudiant la vulnérabilité.
J'ai appris tout ça
en étudiant la honte.
Je veux donc vous expliquer
la honte.
Les jungiens appellent la honte
les marécages de l'âme.
Et nous allons nous y aventurer.
Et le but n'est pas d'y rentrer
et y construire une maison pour y vivre.
C'est de mettre des bottes de caoutchouc
et de les traverser, d’y tracer notre chemin.
Voilà pourquoi :
Nous avons impérativement été appelé
à débattre dans ce pays
et je crois même globalement,
du problème racial, pas vrai ?
Oui ? Nous avons entendu ça.
Oui ?
Nous ne pouvons pas débattre de ça sans avoir honte,
parce que nous ne pouvons pas parler de race sans parler de privilèges.
Et quand on commence à parler de privilèges,
on est paralysé par la honte.
Nous avons entendu une solution simple et astucieuse
pour ne pas tuer les patients en chirurgie,
en tenant une liste de contrôle.
Vous ne pouvez pas résoudre ce problème sans parler de honte,
parce que quand ils enseignent à ces gens à faire des points de suture,
ils leurs apprennent aussi à recoudre leur estime de soi
et devenir tout-puissants.
Et les tout-puissants n'ont pas besoin de listes de contrôle.
Et j'ai dû écrire le nom de ce TED Fellow
pour ne pas me rater.
Myshkin Ingawale,
J'espère que c'est correct.
(Applaudissements)
J'ai vu les conférences TED Fellows le premier jour, ici.
Et il s'est levé et a expliqué
ce qui l'a amené à créer
cette technologie pour améliorer le test pour l'anémie
parce que les gens mouraient inutilement.
Et il disait, « J'ai vu le besoin.
Vous savez ce que j'ai fait ? Je l'ai fabriqué. »
Et tout le monde a commencé à applaudir, avec enthousiasme »
Et il a dit, « Et ça n'a pas marché.
Et je l'ai refait 32 fois,
et ensuite ça a marché. »
Vous savez quel est le grand secret de TED ?
Je meurs d'envie de vous le dire.
Je crois que je vais le faire.
(Rires)
C'est comme la conférence de l'échec.
C'est vrai.
(Applaudissements)
Vous savez pourquoi cet endroit est extraordinaire ?
Parce que peu de gens ici
ont peur de l'échec.
Et aucun de ceux qui montent sur scène, à ce que j'ai vu, n’a jamais échoué.
J'ai échoué misérablement, plusieurs fois.
Je ne crois pas que le monde comprenne que
c'est à cause de la honte.
Il y a une merveilleuse citation qui m'a sauvé l'année dernière
de Theodore Roosevelt.
Beaucoup de gens en parle comme la citation de « L'homme dans l’arène ».
Et elle dit :
« Le critique ne compte pas.
Tout ce qu’il fait c’est pointer du doigt
ce qui aurait pu être mieux fait
et l’homme quand il chute ou quand il se trompe
Le vrai crédit va à celui qui se trouve dans l’arène
avec le visage sali
de poussière, de sueur et de sang.
Car quand il est dans l’arène,
au mieux il gagne,
au pire il perd,
mais même quand il échoue, même quand il perd,
il le fait avec audace ».
Et voilà donc ce qu'est pour moi cette conférence.
Voilà ce qu'est la vie, « Oser avec audace »,
être dans l’arène.
Quand vous rentrer dans l’arène et vous ouvrez la porte,
et vous pensez, « J'y entre et j'essaye, »
La honte est cette petite voix
qui dit, "Uh, uh.
Tu n'es pas assez bonne.
Tu n'as jamais fini ton MBA. Ta femme t'a quitté.
Tu sais que ton père n'était pas vraiment dans le Luxembourg,
il était à Sing Sing.
Je sais ce qui s’est passé dans ton enfance.
Je sais que tu crois ne pas être assez mignonne
ou assez intelligente ou talentueuse ou puissante.
Je sais que ton père ne faisait jamais attention, même quand tu es devenue directeur financier. »
C’est la honte qui parle.
Et si vous arrivez à la faire taire
et dire, « Je vais le faire, »
nous regardons autour et les critiques que nous voyons
qui pointent du doigt et se moquent,
qui sont-ils 99% du temps ?
Nous-même.
La honte à deux grandes méthodes --
« pas assez bon »
et, si vous arrivez à éviter celle-là,
« pour qui te prends-tu ? »
Ce qu'il faut comprendre c’est que la honte n'est pas de la culpabilité.
La honte se concentre sur le soi, la culpabilité sur le comportement.
La honte c'est « Je suis mauvais. »
La culpabilité c'est « J'ai fait quelque chose de mal »
Combien d'entre vous,
si vous faisiez quelque chose qui me blesse,
serait prêts à dire, « Je suis désolé. J'ai fait une erreur ? »
Combien d'entre vous seraient prêts à dire ça ?
Culpabilité : Je suis désolé. J'ai fait une erreur.
Honte : Je suis désolé. Je suis une erreur.
Il y a une énorme différence entre honte et culpabilité.
Et voilà ce qu'il faut que vous sachiez.
La honte est hautement corrélée
avec la dépendance, la dépression, la violence, l'agression,
l'intimidation, le suicide, les désordres de l'alimentation.
Et voici ce qu'il faut que vous sachiez.
La culpabilité est inversement corrélée avec ces choses-là.
La capacité d'utiliser ce que nous avons fait ou échouer à faire
pour nous construire tel que nous nous voulons
est incroyablement adaptative.
C'est pénible, mais adaptatif.
L'autre chose qu'il faut que vous sachiez sur la honte
c'est que c'est totalement organisé par genre.
Si la honte m'envahi ou envahi Chris,
nous nous sentirons de la même façon.
Tous ceux qui sont assis ici connaissent les sensations de la honte.
Nous sommes assez surs que les seules personnes qui n'éprouvent pas de honte
sont celles qui n'ont aucune capacité
de connexion ou empathie.
Ce qui signifie que, oui, j'éprouve un peu de honte;
non, je suis sociopathe.
Je choisirais donc : oui, j'éprouve un peu de honte.
Le sentiment de la honte est pareil pour hommes et femmes,
mais il est organisé par genre.
Pour les femmes,
le meilleur exemple que je puisse vous donner
c'est la pub
de Enjoli:
« Je peux étendre le linge,
préparer le gouter, distribuer des bises
et être au boulot à neuf heure moins cinq.
Je peux ramener du bacon, le cuisiner
et ne jamais te faire oublier que tu es un homme. »
Pour les femmes, la honte c'est tout faire,
le faire parfaitement
et ne jamais montrer que vous êtes fatigué.
Je ne sais combien de parfum cette pub a fait vendre,
mais je vous assure,
ça a fait vendre pas mal d'antidépresseurs et d'anxiolytiques.
(Rires)
La honte, pour les femmes, c'est cette toile
d'attentes inaccessibles et conflictuelles, en concurrence
au sujet de ce que nous sommes supposées être.
C'est comme une camisole de force.
Pour les hommes,
la honte n'est pas tout un tas d'attentes conflictuelles et en concurrence.
La honte est une seule chose
« Ne surtout pas être perçu comment ? »
Faible.
Je n'ai pas interviewé d'homme les quatre premières années de mon étude.
Et ce n'est qu'après qu'un homme m'a regardé pendant une session de dédicace.
en disant, « J'aime ce que vous dite sur la honte,
Je suis curieux, pourquoi vous ne parlez pas des hommes ? »
Et j'ai dit, « Je n'étudie pas les hommes. »
Et il me dit, « C'est trop facile. »
(Rires)
Et j'ai dit, « Pourquoi ? »
Et il me dit, « Parce que vous dite de nous exposer,
de raconter notre histoire,
d'être vulnérable.
Mais vous voyez ces livres que vous venez de signer
pour ma femme e mes trois filles ? »
Je dis, « Oui. »
« Elles préfèreraient me voir mourir sur mon cheval blanc
plutôt que de me voir m'écrouler.
Quand nous essayons de nous exposer et être vulnérables
nous nous faisons massacrer.
Et ne me dites pas
que c'est la faute des copains et des entraineurs et des pères,
parce que les femmes de ma vie sont plus dures avec moi que n'importe qui d'autre. »
J'ai donc commencé à interviewer des hommes
et à leur poser des questions.
Et voici ce que j'ai appris:
Montrez-moi une femme qui peut se tenir devant un homme
en état de vulnérabilité et de crainte,
je vous montrerai une femme qui a fait un travail incroyable.
Montrez-moi un homme qui peut se tenir près d'une femme
qui n'en peut plus,
qui n'arrive plus à tout faire,
et sa première réponse n'est pas,
« J'ai vidé le lave-vaisselle, »
mais qui écoute vraiment --
parce que c'est tout ce qu'il nous faut --
Je vous montrerai un homme qui a fait un grand travail.
La honte est une épidémie dans notre culture.
Et pour en sortir,
pour retrouver la voie qui nous unira,
il nous faut comprendre ses conséquences
et comment elle affecte la manière dont nous élevons nos enfants,
notre manière de travailler, la manière dont nous voyons les autres.
Très rapidement, une recherche de Mahalik au Boston College.
Il a demandé, de quoi les femmes ont-elles besoin pour s’adapter aux règles féminines ?
Les réponses plus fréquentes dans ce pays:
être belle, mince, modeste
et faire de son mieux pour bien paraître.
A la même question pour les hommes,
de quoi les hommes ont-ils besoin
pour s’adapter aux règles masculines,
les réponses ont été:
contrôle des émotions, le travail en premier,
statut social et violence.
Si nous voulons retrouver la voie qui nous ramènera les uns vers les autres,
il nous faut comprendre l’empathie,
parce que l’empathie est l’antidote contre la honte.
Si vous mettez en culture la honte,
elle a besoin de trois choses pour grandir exponentiellement:
secret, silence et jugement.
Si vous mettez en culture la même quantité de honte en la mélangeant avec de l’empathie,
Elle ne peut survivre.
Les deux mots les plus puissants quand nous sommes en difficulté:
« moi aussi ».
Je vais donc vous quitter sur une pensée :
Si nous devons trouvons un moyen
de nous rapprocher les uns des autres,
la vulnérabilité en est le chemin.
Et je sais que c’est alléchant de rester en dehors de l’arène,
parce que je l’ai fait toute ma vie,
en pensant,
Je vais botter le cul à tout le monde
quand je serai blindée et parfaite.
Et c’est alléchant.
Mais la vérité est que ça n’arrive jamais.
Et même si vous arrivez à être aussi parfait que possible
et aussi blindés que possible
en rentrant dans l’arène,
ce n’est pas ce que vous voulez voir.
Nous voulons que vous y rentriez.
Nous voulons être avec vous et en face de vous.
Et nous voulons,
pour nous-mêmes et pour les personnes auxquelles nous tenons
et pour ceux avec qui nous travaillons,
« Oser avec audace ».
Merci beaucoup. Je vous suis très reconnaissante.
(Applaudissements)